first off I want to say thanks to
everyone for for making over here today
I know there's an exciting Jupiter talk
going on actually I want to be there too
I'm also on the PI data committee and so
I'm really excited about this PI data
field I think it's been really fantastic
I hope you've all had a really good time
as well okay so my talk today is about
voce and I've actually given a number of
tutorials about voce over the years at
different PI data conferences but it
occurs to me I think this is the first
talk I've given so excited to have this
opportunity as well so what is voce so
okay well first off who's familiar just
show hands okay a lot of people try to
run through quickly the these parts and
then we're going to add a little bit of
a status update about where sort of
bouquets and we're going to talk about a
few extra things that are sort of being
built on top of or around bouquet as
well so okay the library
to libraries early python and javascript
it's for interactive visualizations that
can have things like widgets or tools we
want able to have very versatile
graphics you know if you don't need just
the stock kind of chart we want to let
you have the flexibility to create all
kinds of customized graphics if you need
them we want to go to handle streaming
and dynamic data possibly large data
sets but this is for the browser right
there the target for all of these is to
be published in modern browsers and
that's theater with or without a server
right so we have a mode for standalone
visualizations and standalone documents
they could still be quite interactive
but also locate server examples that
we'll see a little bit later the biggest
thing though is no Java scripts I'll
repeat that no JavaScript the main sort
of one of the main driving forces behind
bouquet is that we want to let people
stay where they're comfortable where
they're already productive they're happy
and Python or other languages and they
don't want to have to reach to
JavaScript just to make these
interactive visualizations we want to
let them stay where they're already know
very productive and so that's what
bouquets for so we took care to write
all the JavaScript and so you don't have
to so a little Prolog it occurred to me
is we're sort of careening towards a 1.0
release that I'm talking about a little
bit later I was maxing a little
nostalgic so I don't even talk a lot
about myself but I wanted to maybe trace
a few threads of what got me interested
in in boquete in the first place and
what led up to it so hopefully you'll
indulge me just a few minutes so who
first or who remembers logo few folks so
logo was really cool I loved it as a kid
I think I had a cartridge on like trs-80
rhyming language very simple I had this
little turtle and you could tell it to
draw you could tell to move forward turn
left rotate to put a pin up put it down
and draw and what struck me about it at
the time was it with very simple
commands you could make very complicated
output and that's sort of my first
introduction to sort of graphics and
drawing things and that really made an
impression on me I guess note to myself
it occurs to me I'd be a great book
application to make a logo interpreter
that can draw using bouquet so I might
shred you that's for the next PI data
conference beyond that the next thing
that I sort of interacted was frak
tenders anyone remember this program at
all no one probably is the dots program
let you draw fractals and what at the
time I thought was really amazing was
that you could connect pictures you know
to math and you can actually zoom in and
out like you could zoom in and out in
these images and it would take
progressively longer and longer to try
the image because as you got further in
the precision was more and more and so
it would take much longer to zoom way in
but I loved it you know when I was
younger and I thought it was really cool
you could connect sort of mathematical
ideas directly to two images might
that's very important much later when I
started my career I encountered things
like Monty Python and pill this was in
the late 90s there was a library lost to
memory and time that you could use to
create little bar charts and pie charts
in reports in Apache and so I worked at
a wafer fab at the time and so we we use
this to generate these reports and I was
just amazed I was like this is
incredibly to have real data coming in
real time and you can generate these
picture you know right on the fly and I
thought that was really awesome by any
standards today they were very
simplistic but at the time you know I
was truly truly impressed around the
same time I also made my first
contribution to open source software so
the first exposure to it really and that
was the VP case of etk is the
visualization toolkit anyone familiar
with BTK a few folks it is an enormous
C++ library for 3d visualization
pipelines
it has bindings in Python and I think
perl and tickle even but I was using it
for some projects at work and so I
forget what my contribution was but it
was some minor contribution but as I
would later find out in my own life
minor contributions are really great to
have they really add up and so I made my
first contribution there a little bit
later I worked on another open source
library quite a bit more it's called
choco choco was a bit contemporaneous
with map pot late
sort of I think it was a foot race for a
little little while and then eventually
Matt bought live one out chalk was
really geared towards interactive
visualizations in rich clients and it
was really nice but I think there were
some lessons to learn for it from it it
was definitely very fiddly I was kind of
verbose and so it's kind of hard to put
together and so I'd like to think that
I've learned some lessons from chaco
that we've been able to pull forward
into bokeh a little bit later I also
work on Conda so after coming to
continuum
I was one of the first people to work on
Conda and the thing I learned from that
is that you know eventually users start
paying attention if they start using
your software and they care that it
works and that it's stable and that's a
pretty important lesson to learn it's
nice you know the nice thing about one
of project starts is you don't have any
users right and you can make whatever
changes you want but that's a maybe not
such a nice thing after all
and then finally voce really sort of
ties all of those lessons together and
brought us to where we are today bouquet
was started about four years ago and as
I mentioned we're sort of heading
towards the plateau of stability I'm
going to talk about that in a minute so
welcome to voce if you aren't already
familiar with it if you are familiar
with it hope you'll see some new stuff
today as well about voce as well as some
of these other libraries that I'm going
to mention but you know it's certainly
been my privilege and I'm very grateful
for the opportunity to work on an open
source project like ok that I really
care about just to be able to give it
away to you know to everyone
so just to give a little bit of context
for voce I think at five pi three years
ago we had just released 0.5 and sort of
where we were I'm pretty floored by the
numbers today I you know I'm not
actually sure what to say about that
they don't really register with me but
apparently people are using boquete and
that's you know really exciting for me I
always like to try to get people
involved both in using bouquet and also
developing bouquet and becoming new
contributors so we try to be a very
welcoming project and I'm really excited
about that well I think we just passed
237 contributors and again a lot of
these contributions are very small
contributions but that's fantastic those
contributions add up and I promise you
that any open-source maintainer who gets
a PR from you for any amount of work big
or small will be glad to have it and so
I encourage everyone to become involved
with open source if you can but there
are a lot of people that are involved in
making bouquets sort of a core team
that's worked on it on and off and other
people have worked on it on and off
over the years as well but certainly a
lot of contributors and there's a lot of
people active on the mailing list and on
getter and on Stack Overflow
asking and answering questions ok so
let's take a look at what ok is sort of
today and then again we'll move on to
some other topics so ironically the
first thing I wanna mention is actually
not about Python even though we're at PI
data the first thing I want to mention
is that bouquet bouquet has recently
added a more formal JavaScript or really
typescript interface so we're actually
in the process of porting the entire
bouquet j/s library to typescript I
think it's going to be a really good
thing for long term maintenance of
bouquet but there's also now a tight
script API that you can use bouquet
guess as a standalone or self-contained
JavaScript library to generate
visualizations now again a lot of people
can some want to use the Python bindings
for bouquet and we we love those but
we're trying to get more people
interested in using bouquet we're trying
to make bouquet a little bit more of a
normal javascript library so that we can
get more people involved in developing
and using it directly as a JavaScript
library so this is just an example of
what some code looks like it's actually
not very different excuse me not very
different from the Python code which is
nice so Matias pop pop rawski has done a
lot of work on book ajs and on this API
and so again it's very similar to the
Python code which is actually quite nice
some other examples some high level
charts you can create very simply with
dope ajs so this is all of the code to
generate all of those charts with no kjf
you know you get a pie chart you get a
box chart they automatically come with
things like little hover tooltips and
pop-ups so you can find out more about
that from the user's guide online but
the main I guess overriding reason for
the Bukit project of the whole is we
want to make it simple for people to
write data science applications that are
in the browser that are interactive or
they can deal with streaming data it can
do with large data and we want to make
it very simple to write so just there's
a lot of screenshots here some examples
I'm going to go run some demos here in
just a bit but what do you mean by
simple to write data fine
data science apps we mean that you can
concentrate on what you're doing they're
written in Python pretty much entirely
now there's possibilities for using
javascript to augment things but by and
large you can write entirely in Python
you don't have to worry about HTML or
CSS or a lot of web tech again the idea
is you can stay where you're productive
and not have to sort of reach for extra
tools when they're not necessary it's
also very simple Python I'll show some
examples of code and
a bit but it's just simple Python
scripts there's not necessarily any
special classes or frameworks that you
have to plug into if you look at the
code for book a server application looks
just like a simple script that you might
write you might write anytime okay so is
also useful for exploratory analysis but
sharing or publishing Boca course works
in the Jupiter notebook we're working
currently on making it work better in
Jupiter lab but it's also good for
creating these applications or you can
embed standalone documents in class or
tornado or pyramid or cherry-pie apps
whatever it's easy to embed lokay in all
kinds of ways it's easy to publish these
apps the bouquet server is actually very
scalable if you write these bouquets
server applications you can put them
bind a load balancer they vary
horizontally scalable if you have a lot
of users or if the app itself there's a
lot of work you can scale them up very
fairly straightforwardly but the main
thing that it does the actual single
task is probably the most important
thing that the bouquet server does is
that it automatically mirrors the Python
side to the JavaScript side so what do I
mean by that so on the Python side you
have a bunch of objects and call these
thing models they represent things like
your plot or the axes of the plot or the
data for the plot tools or widgets or
layouts things like that there's a
corresponding model in the JavaScript
side sort of a one-to-one correspondence
between all of these models and all
their properties the bouquet server
keeps those things in sync and that's
actually a really valuable valuable
feature and it affords a lot of
capabilities so for instance you could
imagine I want to have a the ability to
draw a selection using a lasso tool over
a bunch of scatter points and maybe
based on that selection I want to
compute something I want to compute some
statistical regression for the lines
that I selected or run some kind of
psychic model on it so because of this
synchronization that can happen the
Python side can be informed of that
selection can trigger off running real
Python code and then it can further
update data sources update other models
that represent the data and then of
course the pot can update and so this
two-way communication is what affords
all of the capabilities that we'll see
here in just a minute for boquete server
apps but that's the that's the main
thing that it affords lets you connect
these front-end applications which can
have plots or data tables or all kinds
of things directly to the full PI data
stack and so the full pi data stack is
numpy and scifi pandas and so I could
learn insight gate image and
ass get all of these things so another
thing that well actually let me go out
and show a couple of demos first I'm
going to sort of your super stinks I
have a lot of windows open so I'm just
going to tab over and try to find a
couple of interesting ones right quick
so here's maybe the canonical simple
example of a bouquet application I will
make this bigger by showing this over at
the table and so I had everything
minimized to get as much as possible but
here's a very simple example
it just shows a fine grading I've got
some sliders that let me control the
offset and the amplitude and things like
that and so I can scrub these sliders
and the data update its and so therefore
the plot updates and so I can change the
amplitude or I can change the phase or
the frequency I can say by sine wave for
PI data Seattle and that's nicely uh
will see that the plot update and so
what does the code for that look like
maybe it's instructive to take a quick
look let me go and bring this here
hopefully we'll see that it's fairly
straightforward so I've got a nice stock
string at the top telling me how to run
this example and all these examples by
the way are in the bouquet github repo
right so this is all BSD license
including the server it's all on github
under the bouquet organization so here's
the example I've got my doc string
I've got a few imports from bouquet I
set up some data there's a few lines
here I compute some numpy you know
arrays linspace and compute the sine
curve for the plot itself I've got one
line that creates the plot and then
another line that creates the actual
line that I want to draw a line of code
rather that creates the line that I want
to draw on the plot so that's pretty
much as minimal as I think we can get
and then for each of the widgets there's
again one line as well for a text box
and for sliders I can configure things
like the start and stop regions the
increment that I wanted to - to use
whenever I scrub the slider and then
finally where the work actually happens
is I have some callbacks so if the title
changes its value I want to call this
update title function when all that does
if it sets the plot title to whatever
the textbox value is similarly if any of
the sliders change their value I want to
call this update data function which
simply gets all the values from the
sliders and computes a new
sign curve using those values and then
it sets the data on the data source to
this new value which again causes the
plot to update automatically last I just
I put these things in a layout you know
with a column and then I add them to my
document and I'm done all right so I can
run this similar to the Jupiter notebook
I have a bouquet command I called
bouquets serve on this function on this
script sliders up high and then that
will give me this this application and
so again we can see if I change I change
the title type level plot changes if I
scrub the slider that's used to compute
new data for the plot so that's one
example another example which is maybe a
interesting comparison here this is a
reproduction of the SHINee movie
Explorer in Python and so this is taking
some data about movies and basically
letting you have a little interface that
allows you to query or or dig into this
data I've got a nice hover tooltip that
lets me see you know The Matrix
Revolutions in 2003 made 139 million
dollars you can see that the ones that
are tinted shaded gold are the ones that
won an Oscar I added a little extra bit
here the ones that are shaded purple or
wrathy winter so you can see there was
some wrathy winners that made a lot of
money despite also when you're a Z looks
like that with the transformers so so
what can we do this so we can scrub for
instance the number of minimum reviews
and we can see that this can update you
know filter by the number of dollars of
the box office that was made that sort
of thing minimum number of Oscar wins
obviously that's going to update the
plot as well so again this isn't meant
to be a fairly direct comparison people
have asked question where is shiny for
Python hopefully okay and some of these
other tools I mentioned can fill that
need and fill that gap okay so that's a
good example good one if you go to demo
dot voce plops comm there's actually
several of these example toasted you
take a look at our sliders here's
another example that I like it's fairly
simple this is the auto mpg or cars data
set and it's just a little app that lets
you slice and dice and say I want to see
the displacement versus the horsepower
and maybe I want to shade by you know
maybe I don't want any shading or sorry
they don't want
any size they don't want any shading or
maybe I want to you know change the size
by the mpg and sort of see that change
and all of that just is fairly easy to
write as a book application so that's
another nice one I like to show off
alright that's pretty good oh one last
one here
so this is also another one I like to
show up this is just a reproduction of
Gapminder so you might remember sort of
one of the first famous TED talks at
least the one that the first one I
really remember is this Gapminder data
set that shows life expectancy versus a
fertility rate over time and so here
we've reproduced that chart here we have
a little slider where we can scrub
through and see how this changes over
time and we've added a little play
button and again this is just Python
code there's a Python script that
defines all the elements in this plot
when you press the play button it can
add a little periodic callback to
actually advance the slider which causes
it to update but it's similar to that
sliders doc UI example that I showed
it's not very much code it's again in
github under the examples app directory
you can see all of these okay all right
let me go ahead and get back to a few
slides for a minute so another thing
that boquete can handle really well is
streaming data right and so that fairly
recently I guess was in last year maybe
a little bit more we've added some
methods to our column data source the
column data sources sort of the
foundational fundamental data object in
boquete that's used to transfer data
between Python and the browser and we
added some methods to it that can be
useful in certain use cases so there's a
stream method if you have the use case
where you're incrementally sort of
marginally adding data to the end of
like a time series say and you're not
updating the first data points but
you're adding data points to the end the
stream data can be used to do that in a
much more efficient way so you can
always sort of stream data to Boca by
just changing all of your data but then
you're sending all of the data every
time and so that can be not as efficient
so the stream is very useful if you need
to append to the data I'll see an
example that in a minute and there's
also a dot patch to the column data
source which allows you to update random
points in the middle so you could
imagine if you have a large image and
you want to change for instance just a
region of the image in the middle you
can basically do numpy slicing to update
just the tiny subset of an image instead
of sending the entire data for the new
image so that can be useful as well that
effects is going to be used with
in conjunction with the data shader
project that I'm mentioning a little bit
later to do some streaming data scatter
plots we'll talk about that later let's
actually see a streaming example right
quick so again this this streaming
example is not using that stream API but
it's just sending a new set of data for
the coordinates every iteration and
that's fine if you have a small amount
of data but again if you have a lot of
data probably want to try to do
something a little bit better and so
this example is maybe a little bit more
instructive this is a market simulation
so there's one script it computes the
synthetic market data it's just a log
normal distribution it computes the open
high low close it computes these other
indicators I think they're called MACD
indicators at the bottom I'm not such a
finance person it creates these widgets
up top to let you change the I can
change the mean if I want to get really
rich I can increase that mean of the
simulation or I can make it really
volatile maybe I want to see a different
exponential moving average instead of
the one that I had and so all the codes
do all of that and to have this scalable
deployable web app I don't know how many
code how many lines of code do you think
you could do that in people always
lowball the answer but it's done it's
under 100 lines of code right so I mean
if you can have a sort of a scalable
deployables streaming data computing the
synthetic data providing this
interaction automatically with widgets
and under 100 lines of Python I think
you're doing pretty good I can brag a
little bit so that's that's example
again you can see the the code for that
on github if we go to github.com maybe
worth showing explicitly
go to here so this is the bouquet github
there's actually a bouquet organization
with a few other repos in it but if you
go to the examples app directory there's
several examples here there's selection
histogram which maybe I don't have
running but cross filter one that I ran
earlier the Gapminder one that I ran
earlier movies
this one is ohlc for open high/low close
and again we can look at the main pie
for it is not too much Python code and
fairly simple straight forward Python
code there's actually no classes here
it's just a fairly simple strip not that
you can't use classes if you want to
create or create classes and organize
your application more comprehensively
you can certainly do that but boquete
doesn't require anything like that try
to keep it very simple and accessible
for everybody okay so the next thing is
to mention custom extensions so maybe
also about a year ago we realized that
as much as we want to do with okay we'll
never ever be able to satisfy every
possible use case that you just come up
with two users have really awesome
interesting use cases and they have a
lot of things that they want to do that
are perfectly reasonable and sensible to
do or to want to do but then maybe don't
make sense to put in the core library
because then it adds the maintenance
burden to the you know the few core
developers to work on bouquet and so we
decided that the thing to do was to make
bouquet more easily extensible and so
it's possible to create these models as
I said a model as a thing like a plot or
an axis or a data source it's possible
to create your own models that have
their own JavaScript implementation that
you can then use just like a regular
bouquet model right so you can create
some custom div here it's a special
slider display that does something
special maybe it displays the slider in
a different way or wrap some other
JavaScript slider but if you change the
value then automatically these
properties the text and slider
properties that are mirrored in the
Python implementation automatically get
synchronized just like any other bouquet
model gets synchronized automatically
and so this is a very powerful way for
adding extensions so you can use this to
add capability for things like wrapping
different widgets so bouquet has a range
slider built in maybe you don't like it
maybe you want to use the island range
slider which have some nice facilities
maybe there's some other fancy
JavaScript library of the week you want
to be able to connect to Python
analytical code you can use these
extensions to wrap those widgets in fact
this was used specifically by Sir bird
who's a great locate Avella / on a
particular project and she wanted to use
this ion range slider so she wrapped it
and it works really great so you can
also use it to adapt something like a 3d
library so bouquet itself does not have
any 3d capability built in at the moment
I don't know what the future will bring
but we know right now it's really
focused on 2d visualizations and that's
great but you know maybe you want to
wrap some 3d library
so there's several 3d JavaScript
libraries that you could use you could
connect to again Python you can connect
to numpy and sci-fi and pandas by making
an extension to Rapson so there's an
example surface 3d that does exactly
that and you can see that in fact take a
quick look don't know if I have it
running but go to demo double okay pause
comm we can see how things work over the
conference Wi-Fi so this is again so I
wrapped this visit so business is kind
of a simple toy 3d library but I chose
it just for simplicity but I made a
little extension that wraps it and so
whenever I update the data source
it automatically adapts it to whatever
visit Jas is expecting there's basically
just a few lines of JavaScript
translation code and now I have this
updating interacting 3d plot and that's
true for a lot of things so anything
that you want to put on the front end
and connect to Python bouquet can offer
you a pathway to do that
another thing you can currently do is
for instance adlai tech labels so I hope
to be able to add more support built-in
to bouquet for this this is asked for a
lot especially from academic corners we
currently have an example now where you
can use the contact library to add latex
labels in and around your plot again I
hope some day we can add a little bit
more built-in integration but this is a
nice feature in the meantime it lets you
still have capability even though it's
something is not in the core library
that's the way the basis of this whole
extension mechanism is that the
community doesn't have to wait for us
it's also maybe a nice way to lower the
bar for contributions people can create
a custom extension they don't have to
get involved in the full development or
full building of the bouquet library
it's kind of a you know it's much better
than it used to be but it's still a
little bit of a burden tap to pull down
the source and build the JavaScript and
build the Python and so it's a little
bit of work but this allows you to do it
without having to modify you can just
install a standard release of bouquet
right and extension and then if it's
something really useful you can present
it to the community and might be a path
to getting into the core library
eventually or maybe it's something you
can share and I hope to have a better
mechanism for sharing these kinds of
extensions making them more discoverable
across the community I think that we
really magnified their value that's
something we try to do before 1.0 so
putting all that together I'll show
another example that I've been working
on on and off in different ways actually
for quite a while since in the beginning
of ok and it's this nice spectrogram
example and the reason that I like to
show it now is that the first time I
wrote this example when bouquet was
first starting was almost entirely
written in CoffeeScript so bouquet jess
is actually written in CoffeeScript and
it's about 600 lines of CoffeeScript and
so there was like a little bit of Python
bouquet and then 600 lines it's big
giant pile of JavaScript that's you know
it was nice to look at but that's not I
don't want to write 6-under lines of
JavaScript and I'm sure most people here
at PI data probably don't either so over
the years I've been trying to add you
know the features and get to the goal of
being able to write a pure Python
application that really has the
spectrogram capability pretty much there
there's a little bit of a custom
extension this that actually could be
gotten rid of with our new patch
capability I just haven't had a chance
yet but so this is a nice example I
think so this is reading my microphone
showing the signal here it's showing a
power spectrum here it's doing the
Fourier transform in the waterfall plot
and there's just a fun little graphic
sort of equalizer that just a bending of
the power spectrum around around the
outside of a circular a little plot
there just for fun I'm sorry ah so I so
this isn't to be an illustrative example
if you really want to make a very
precise spectrogram you probably need
something a little better I guess here's
a nice demonstration oh thank you for
asking so let's see so this will be fun
because at a previous conference
Peter Wang who was the co-founder of
continuum but also one of the other
people behind voce these who I worked on
or who I worked with on choco many years
ago he instructed me to whistle and to
middle of one of my talks whereupon
everyone found out I don't have a
whistle but so let me go ahead and find
a tone generator and so we can maybe see
something a little bit better here so we
can see a nice spike we go ahead and
increase
things they're got a nice little pick
maybe a square wave or whatever we want
so it's really kind of cool
I don't know I'm happy to be able to
have this kind of capability doable
pretty much entirely from Python a
little bit later this year I will have a
pure Python version where there's not
even the small custom extension that's
currently used for the streaming but
that's sort of we're been trying to get
to and that's sort of one of the
implicit you know not like a explicit
goal of the project but it's sort of it
helped us drive direction because we
knew we wanted to get to being able to
do this kind of thing with pure Python
yeah I think that's probably right so
there is possible to scale this down but
I think the sampling rate is probably
not like it's not a very high sampling
rate either so I think definitely I've
run this through songs and just depends
I'm not a speech audio expert as well
just an area where if you want to make
this better I would love to have a
discussion and collaborate and try to
make this something that's even more
actually useful than just you know
demonstrative yeah that might just have
to do again with the sampling rates that
I've chosen I'm using by the way I'm
using PI audio for this pi audio is kind
of hard to install in a lot of platforms
but recently thanks to Philip Ruettiger
there's a synthetic mode now where you
can just run it it'll actually just run
some synthetic synthetic data through so
you can just see it operate and see it
run without actually having to add pi PI
audio installed ok cool we'll close that
one down
great anyway so that's that's bouquet so
if for anyone is curious about this
axial image that's here where did this
come from
it was a postmodern jukebox which is a
lot of fun they take pop songs and they
read on rifai them and I think this was
their version to take it off that they
were doing I took that image from
another thing that's really important to
mention about about bouquet is it is not
necessarily just for Python so I
mentioned that there are really two
libraries there's Bill kgs in the client
there's the Python library the way they
communicate is by a declarative JSON
specification that they pass back and
forth might be over WebSocket for the
server for performance reasons but any
language that can generate the right
pile of JSON can create these bouquet
pots in the browser so Ryan Haven who's
a big R person he's one of our
collaborators on the DARPA X data
initiative
he likes bouquet but he's a big art
person so he made our bouquet and I'm
actually happy to please be able to say
that there's been some funding recently
to continue working on our bouquet and
to make it even more stable and
maintainable in the long term and so our
book is a pretty nice facility already
you can go check out - da Shi o / our
bouquet and get a better feel for all
the kind of things you can do with our
bouquet and improvements are being added
as we speak there's also a bouquet Scala
binding one of the core bouquet devs
mateus pop pop rocks key he's actually a
big scala fan I think he's probably like
Scala more than Python actually but he's
so he's made bindings for bouquet in
Scala and really any language you want
you could you know create bindings for
so there used to be a polka dot JL
binding the person that maintained that
eventually had to move on to other
things I would love to see a Julia
finding her bouquet sort of come to life
again anyone knows jewelry and is
interested would love to work on that
I've threatened for a while to make a
like a MATLAB bouquet binding but I
don't think I would ever do that so but
anyway the principle is there is that
lots of languages could make use of
bouquet and to use you know bouquet to
generate visualizations in the browser
all right so what are what's coming up
so I think it's been asked for for a
long time is PNG and SVG export and
that's done very happy to report a
long-standing issue last release 0.12
point 6 we actually finally were able to
add that there are a number of
I guess technical trade-offs and hurdles
that sort of led to that not being an
easy thing to do but you can now
programmatically head look the export
TNG's or SVG's of individual canvases so
that's happy Network and graph rendering
this is also another long-standing issue
so you've always been able to draw
networks of graphs in boquete if you lay
all the data out in Python you can just
send the coordinates for the visual
shapes to book ajs but bokadia then
doesn't know anything about the actual
graph data as graph data you can't just
say I want to find all the neighbors of
a node or something it doesn't know
anything about the graph structure so
this is really to add some knowledge of
graph structures of okay Jas and
rendering there's an open PR for that
I'm also happy to say that's also part
of some funded work so that is going to
be ongoing and that should be in the
next release binary array protocol so
the book the low-level book a server
protocol is actually already built to be
able to handle multiple chunk buffers we
just have really taken good advantage of
that yet and so what I'd like to do
hopefully the next release may be the
one after is to be able to send things
like numpy arrays without copying them
in to the extent possible we use factory
just adjacent everything and that works
but was pretty slow in a lot of cases we
then move to actually a base64 encoding
for numeric arrays and that sped things
up quite a bit but there's still a lot
of room there which is actually a great
place to be when you have low-hanging
fruit and so I think we can basically
spend numpy arrays fairly directly
straight into the JavaScript types of
rays without you know a minimal of
copying I think it's going to offer a
pretty big performance benefits in
certain use cases so excited about that
better Jupiter lab support as I
mentioned you know there's a big duper
lab talk going on right now and dooper
lab is sort of the way forward for all
of Jupiter and we want to make sure the
book integrates with it really well so
they have their new mime extension
mechanism want to make sure boquete uses
that for standalone plots and then for
embedded server plots
make that work as well probably using
iframes we also want to do Altair and
Vega like integration so if you're
familiar with Jeff here it's also here
and Jake Vander Plaats who gave a great
keynote the other day you know there's
Altair and Vega light of these other
adjacent specifications for very high
level plotting we'd like to be able to
turn those into bouquet plots I think
there's a couple of reasons for that
Jake mentioned that he loved a good
altaïr plots to be able to be saved as
PNG s and SVG so if they can convert all
terror into bouquet they can save them
as SVG s and P and G's now I also think
it's a nice may be possible workflow
where people can create high level
charts with Altair or or Vega light but
can then add extra bells and whistles to
write bouquet has all this capability
for you know embedding in layouts as
widgets and adding custom J's callbacks
or attaching to a server and all that
would work fine you could sort of start
with your base plot you easily create
with altera Vega light and then adorn it
with a lot of bouquet functionality
animations and smooth transitions
something Peters really excited about
we'll get to that eventually as well
also making bouquet J as a first-class
project again Java Script library the
JavaScript programmers might want to use
or contribute to I'll take full full
responsibility bouquet dance is kind of
a weird oddball JavaScript library I
didn't really know any JavaScript when I
wrote it and sort of got by on the
strength of my previous experience
working on visualization tools but it's
kind of a weird library and so we're
trying to clean it up converted type
script make it more easily installable
and usable and something that other
JavaScript developers might want to look
at also want to expand WebGL capability
there's some current partial WebGL
capability it's a little bit hard to
maintain the people that were
maintaining WebGL capability don't
really work on bouquet anymore but I
want to look at a library called regal
which I've seen some really good things
about lately which i think would be a
better fit for bouquet in terms of
adding expanded WebGL and more
supportable WebGL capability so one look
at that soon as well and then 1.0 so we
have two releases plan 0 12 7 and 0 12 8
and then a round of more polished and
clean up and then we want to have our
1.0 release so this is pretty much the
list of important things we want to try
to do before 1.0 and it's not a very big
list although some of the tasks are
somewhat involved but apart from that of
course there's lots of again polished
and bug fixing and expanding the docs
and things like that but I'm happy to
say that we're not reaching a point of
completion but really you know a point
of plateau stability we want to make
bouquet something very stable for other
projects to build on so let's talk about
some of those so one of them is howl of
use so howl of use first let me say
should be considered a replacement for
bouquet charts so we tried to add a very
high level charting API directly to
bouquet the again it's a matter of
maintenance the folks that worked on
that don't really work
anymore and when you have to allocate
scarce resources you have to make
decision we decided to trying to make
the core book as solid as possible with
the best use of resources especially
because there was this other project
called views which already existed and
was great and they added voce
integration I worked with some of the
developers as my colleagues I would say
how the views has already surpassed
where Boca sharks was in pretty much
every regard and I would encourage
everyone to use it going forward if you
want a high level interface on top of
Boquete for sort of exploratory data
analysis you know very high level Halla
views is what you wanted so let's take a
look at some examples so really the idea
behind ecology is that you annotate your
data so here you might have a panda's
data frame and i want to specify what
are the key dimensions what are the
value dimensions and then i just call
scatter ah I get a scatter and that's
fairly simple and basic and something
you would expect and hopefully not too
much too much work but you can also do
things like have compositional layout
very simply so here for instance I've
got my scatter and I might want to call
HP histogram on the histogram of the
data and now I can simply get this nice
layout without having to expressly
import or call you know row or column
layout primitives another thing we can
do with how the views of slice and dice
so here I've got a bunch of data and I
want to use this DF dot select to select
a few different states and a few
different years there and then I want to
pass that to my all of these bar charts
and now I get this nice grouped bar
automatically you know cyclos colors
that sort of thing automatically
generates a legend so again it's a very
high level interface on top of Boca and
I would encourage everyone to take a
look at it another thing we can do is
easily interact with our data so how the
views as I said it's really as opposed
to a data visualization language it's
almost a visualization data language and
it's kind of a subtle distinction but
it's really about annotating what are
the different dimensions of your data so
that all of yous can decide what to do
with it so you can say I want to attach
these dimensions to visual quantities
and if I don't do anything with the last
dimension how abuse can for instance
automatically pop up a slider so now
that I can scrub through and see the
different hours and as I mentioned if
you actually look at one of these
hollows objects you can see that it
really is just it's the data with some
image you know the image data is for
instance an x-ray or an umpire
but then there's some annotations that
specify what are the different
dimensions represent going back easily
in Iraq you can also create voce server
applications with them right so holidays
now allows you to create bouquets or
applications with perhaps considerably
less code so here for instance is
instead about that hollow map from the
last slide it's called a dynamic map
there's a function called interactive
clipper that I'm not showing here but
it's in the documentation which creates
this Clifford fractal and it's simply
this is the entire amount of code right
I give it that interactive clifford that
can generate the actual data for the
drawing and pass it to my dynamic map
set my ranges it can automatically
attach the stream for the pointer so now
i have this interactive pointer it
creates sliders automatically for the
things that the dimensions i haven't
specified visual properties for and
everything is sort of here so let's take
a look i go back at maybe a couple of
actual examples from all of you
so first off the howl of use
documentation is fantastic I'm
embarrassed to say that the howl of use
deaths actually managed to use the PNG
export capability before I was able to
use it to automatically generate
thumbnails for their gallery and they
have a quite extensive gallery they have
a lot of things going on here in their
gallery they also have this reference
gallery that's sort of for more simple
you know simple task oriented gallery
that's here but they also have the the
main gallery which is a bit more
sophisticated examples anyway we can
take a look at a bunch of those here's a
nice one I like this Musial's example I
probably seen this chart in various
guises but this they break up their
examples nicely as well they talk about
how do we declare the data and how we
specify dimensions and then how do we
specify the visual properties of our
data we want to plot and that's a bit
different so here we go so this is a
nice spot it has all of this and it's
not too much code to generate I think
I'm actually running way behind time
show a couple more things
there was the measles one this
sorry oh here we go coming back to
fractals here's a nice bouquet
application that excuse me uses all of
you to generate bouquet application then
again now can update and I can update
the histogram on the side it sort of
comes back to that fracked int saying
that I had before they wrote that as
well this is also using data shader
which I guess I may not actually have
too much time to talk about this is a
full 15 million point data set the New
York City Taxi data set and it's
generating that cross-section using
number to efficiently slice that out and
again hall of use to sort of compose
those things together maybe in the last
couple of minutes here I should try to
say at least a couple of words about
data shader at least the slides I got
two minutes is that correct
one minute okay sorry I like doing demos
all right so last few seconds here then
data shader is a library for dealing
with larger data sets if you have a lot
of points you have implicit problems
with them over plotting you saturate all
the pixels you can try to apply alpha
you still can end up with over plotting
if you set the altitude low it's under
plotting bidding problems if you decide
to do that so data shader is a pipeline
for doing rendering tries to solve some
of these problems automatically and
across large data sets it works really
well with bouquet if you use I have that
slide in the wrong place remind ask miss
you spy bouquet to create a nice
dashboard lastly there's some resources
here if you download the slides from
link I gave at the beginning and lastly
just you know download it try it
contribute and if it's appropriate
engage with us some work all the
commercial engagements definitely help
support bouquet and help us inform our
open source so sorry I didn't leave
enough time for questions
or maybe I did I don't know was that
five minutes the question we have room
for one quick question and then probably
five minutes till the next session do we
have a quick question here yes so in the
beginning you had talked about how
bouquet was used for exploration and for
data visualization I'm assuming after
modeling
can you speak maybe a little bit about
what lokay might look if you were trying
to put it into production if you wanted
to show like a client something and
things like that yeah sure so there's a
couple of different ways to use bouquet
the first decision you probably want to
make is do I need to run real Python
code you know in response to event and
if the answer is no then you can use
what's called a standalone document if
these we're great in either exported
static notebooks they work great in
embedding in a flask or app it's just
very simple it's just HTML and
JavaScript you could send it to an email
there's no server required if you want
to have actual Python code run if that's
you know what you want to do a selection
triggers a scikit-learn
run or something like that then you want
to use the bouquet server and so then
there's a little bit more to deal with
because you have to figure out how do I
learn deploy this there's quite a lot of
instruction in the user's guide about
how to deploy behind for instance nginx
or behind Apache and there probably some
services the next year that help
automate that orchestration and there's
a lot of information on the mailing list
as well but that's the first decision to
make is do I need to run Python code if
I do I want the server and if I don't
then I can probably get away with the
standalone app which will be a little
bit simpler in terms of deployment but
the code is like if you look at the
examples under examples app they're all
fairly straightforward simple scripts to
run it you just run bouquets serve on
the directory or the script and again if
you need to scale out they're typically
horizontally scalable they don't share
states so you can just run more behind a
load balancer if you if you need if you
have ten users you can run one if you
have you know ten million users or
something you might need to run quite a
few more depending on what the app does
it's sort of a trade-off between how
much work does the app actually do
where's how many users right I mean we
can't predict okay doesn't make the work
disappear right
it's got to be spread across you know
whatever amount of compute you have and
so that ratio is going to depend on what
the app does and how many users you have